27 ans plus tard la france assume
finalement son implication dans le
massacre rouennais ce mercredi le
gouvernement a annoncé la
déclassification des archives de
l'ex-président françois mitterrand et de
son premier ministre de l'époque edouard
balladur
objectif annoncé faire avancer la vérité
historique
ma responsabilité elle est de veiller à
ce que ces crimes soient connus de nos
élèves et que ce soit un objet
d'histoire et que cet objet d'histoire
puisque évidemment imprégner les
consciences
cet enseignement participe de la
transmission d'une culture historique
partagé qui doit être aussi une culture
historique à baiser dans un rapport
dirigé par l'historien vincent duclert
et publiée le 26 mars dernier de
nombreux télégrammes diplomatiques ou
encore des notes confidentielles
mettez en lumière le soutien que l'état
français avait à l'époque apportés au
régime génocidaire août où ce sont les
autorités françaises qui effectivement
dans ce dossier ont des responsabilités
accablante 1 parce que eh bien pendant
trois ans au lieu de finalement de
soutenir la démocratisation du rwanda et
la peur au rwanda au fond ces autorités
ont soutenus
l'ethnicisation soutenu la
radicalisation du gouvernement si le
président de l'association ebouquin qui
défend la mémoire du génocide rwandais a
salué le soutien que la france apporte
au rwanda il réclame des excuses
nationales les rescapés n'ont pas
beaucoup quoi rendre une de ses
productions négligence et le savent ils
ont vécu
ils veulent les actes forts du veulent
que des mots sont prononcés
parce que 27 ans après
certains d'entre eux ne sont plus tout
jeunes qu'il attendait une parole forte
quand les chercheurs de travailler dans
des histoires deviennent de travailler
il faut que les policiers n'auraient il
faut que les juges près les derniers
chiffres de l'onu sur le génocide au
rwanda estime que sur sept millions
d'habitants que comptait le pays en 1994
un million de personnes majoritairement
des tutsi ont été exterminés dans des
conditions abominables
entre avril et juillet 1994 le rôle de
la france dans le massacre reste un
sujet sensible
un quart de siècle plus tard dans une
volonté de rapprochement diplomatique le
président de la république a prévu
d'effectuer une visite officielle à
kigali
d'ici au mois de mai un déplacement qui
reste toutefois soumis à l'évolution de
la situation sanitaire